[موسيقى]
احييكم اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه التي
نستاهلها كالعاده بابرز العناوين
عمران خان يتعرضوا لمحاوله اغتيال فاشله
وقوات الامن تقتل احد المشتبهي بهم وتلقي
القبض على اخر
روسيا تقصف منشات الطاقه الاوكرانيه ولا
بروف يتهموا كيف باستخدام الممرات المائيه
لاغراض عسكريه والاخيره تنفي
[تصفيق]
رغم بالمواجهات بين المحتاجين الايرانيين
وقوات الامن فيرج ومسيره تنطلق لاحياء ذكر
ضحايا التظاهرات
رغم التجارب بها الصاروخيه كوريا الشماليه
تحذر جارتها الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده
من تمديد مناورتهما العسكريه
اهلا بكم واصيب رئيس الوزراء الباكستانيه
سابق عمران خان برصاصه في قدمه خلال
التجمع السياسيين اليوم لكنه في حاله
مستقره وفق مقاله احد مساعديه وقال مراسل
العربيه ان اصابه عمران خان في قدمه طفيفه
وهو في حاله مستقره مضيفا ان قياده في حزب
الانصاف من بين المصابين في الهجوم في وقت
اكد فيه مساعده
الموقف والقبض على اخره من جانبه قال رؤوف
حسن احد كبار مساعد
يتقدم مسيره منذ جمعه الماضي من مدينه
لاهور نحو العاصمه اسلام اباد في اطار
حمله للمطالبه بانتخابات جديده بعد ما
اقصى من منصبه في الربيع
رئيس الوزراء الباكستانيه السابق والنجم
الكريكيت عمران خان والذي تعرض لمحاولات
اغتيال خلال مظاهره قادها للمطالبه
بالانتخابات المبكره اشتهر بمواقفه
المثيره للجدل خاصه اتهامه للولايات
اتهامه للولايات المتحده بمحاوله الاطاحه
به اثناء رئاسته وزراء باكستان
[موسيقى]
كاريكا
دكتور رضا
السياسات والعلاقات الدوليه دكتور اهلا بك
معنا محاوله فاشله لاغتيال عمران خان رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق الان كيف يمكن
ان يتوقع ان يكون المشهد في باكستان خاصه
في ظل التوترات الحاصله اصلا هناك
همم
رئيسي الوزراء السابق سوف تدعو الى المزيد
من حالتي الاستقطاب السياسيه في الباكستان
وسوف تزيد من حجم الاختلافات بين الاحزاب
والقيادات السياسيه
والان سوف تكون هناك التبعات واتهامات
سياسيه واضحه وبهذه الطريقه
قد تكونوا علامه اخرى على حاله عدم
الاستقرار السياسي في البلاد
نعم اشعر ببالغ الخلق ولو نظرتم
ان عمران خان كان قد استثمر فتره طويله
حول هذه المسيره
والحشد الناس هذا شهر يعده
حاسما بالنسبه هناك تغيير لرئيس السيسي
هيئه الاركان وهناك ايضا ضغوط من قبل هناك
ضغوط من قبل لحزب السيد عمران خان
والحكومه التي كانت رفضت الحمله
الانتخابيه قبل موعدها هذه التوترات اذا
ما استمرت فقد تحمل اثار متضاعفه وسوف
تؤثر على وضع الاستقرار في البلاد واذا ما
كان هناك تاثير على سياده القانون وتقويض
الاستقرار السياسي وهي في وضع سيء سلفا
فهذا قد يقضي الى
تحركا غير ده سوري مما سوف يحدث المزيد من
التدهور في البلاد
مش قادر على احتواء الامور الان
عاده
ان الجيش سواء كان قادرا من عدمه فا من
الواضح بان الجيش حتى اللحظه كان قد اعطى
انطباعا بانه ليس له اي طابع سياسي رغم
عدم تصديقنا لهذا الامر ولكن هذه الصوره
وقد
تتغير من على مر ما حدث خلال ساعه قليل
الماضيه والنجاه الرئيسي همم
الوزراء السابق ونامل الا تتطور الامور
ومن المؤكد انه اذا ما همم كان هناك
تغيرات فان الجيش قد يتدخل ل- اا يمسك
بزمان الامور بمجرد دخول الجيش فانه سوف
يقوم همم
لا يمكن للمراه ان يستثني اي شيء في عقاب
هذا الحادث شكرا لك
استاذ السياسات والعلاقات الدوليه مازلنا
تبع همم لمحاوله الاغتيال التي همم اطالت
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان ينضم الى
الان من الاسلام اباد مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن المزيني عبد الرحمن اهلا بك معنا
ماذا لدينا من جديد ماذا هناك من تفاصيل
جديده اذا توفرت
ان ابدا هنا بالبيان الذي صدر عنه متحدث
العسكريين المتحدث باسم الجيش الباكستاني
الذي ندد باسم القوات المسلحه بمحاوله
اغتيال رئيس وزراء السابق عمران خان
وقال بانه يدعو وهمم عبر عن عن همم تعطفه
مع الجرحى ودع لهم بالشفاء العاجل وزيره
الاعلام مريم زيب عقدت مؤتمر صحفيا قبل
قليل ادعت فيه الى ضبط النفس واكدت ان
الحكومه المركزيه مستعده همم تقديم كافه
الدعم والمساعده لحكومه اقليم البنجاب في
التحقيقات الجاريه في محاوله اغتيال رئيس
وزراء السابق عمران لكنها دعت الى ضبط
النفس وانتقدت التصريحات التي صدرت عن عدد
من قاده حزب ان يصعب زعامه عمران خان واا
حذرت من همم
المساس بالنسيج الاجتماعي وان
او اجار محاوله جر البلاد الى الفوضى وعدم
الاستقرار ودعت الى انتظار نتائج التحقيق
التي
ستصدرها شرطه اقليم البنجاب قبل الاصدار
اي تصريحات او استنتاجات سابقه لاوانينها
الان المحققون لا يزالون يعقفون على
التحقيق مع
المشتبه به الرئيس الذي تم القاء القبض
عليه متلبسا في ساحه او في الميدان
مقتل الاخر عبد الرحمن
حتى الان لا يوجد شيء رسمي بخصوص وجود
مشتبه اخر هل هو احد ال ال المحتجين ام
انه كان بالفعل احد المهاجمين حتى الان لا
يوجد تصريح ينفي او يؤكد انه يعني كان احد
المهاجمين او انه ربما احد المتظاهرين
الذين ربما سقطوا جراء اطلاق النار او
بسبب تدافع على الحشود بعد الحادث مع اود
الاشاره اليه الى ان الان عدد من المدن
والبلدات الباكستانيه تشهد مظاهرات عفويه
واحتجاجيه همم
للتعبير عن تضامنها مع رئيس وزراء السابق
عمران خان والتمديد بالحكومه الحاليه
برئاسه الرئيس الوزراء الشهباء الشريف
هناك همم مئات متظاهرين يحاصرون مبنى او
منزل رئيس عفوا منزل وزيره الداخليه رانا
سناء الله الذين يحملونه المسؤوليه عن
محاوله اغتيال رئيس وزراء همم السابق
عمران خان ااا كان ذلك بسبب تصريحات سابقه
له حذر فيها عمران خان واتهمه بانه ااه
راس الفتنه في البلاد وانه فيما لو حاول
جر البلاد فوضت فسيتم التعامل معه بحسن
استخدم هذا التعبير سوف يسحق راسه كما قال
هذه هي التصريحات تصريحات الوزير جاءت بعد
تصريح من المعان خان قال بان المسيره
الطويله التي يقودها سوف تتجه الى الى
تحقيق ايه انجازاتها الى تحقيق الهدف منها
اما عبر صناديق الاقتراع او عبر حمام الدم
دون الاشاره الى ماذا يقصد بالحمام الذهبي
المدن الباكستانيه ام لا مؤشرات على ذلك
ارد الاشاره هنا ان ال ال السلطات العاصمه
استبقت هذه المظاهره منذ اسابيع بوضع عدد
من الحاويات وانا استدعاء تعزيزات من
الشرطه الان تم اغلاق بعض بعض الطرق
الرئيسيه التي خاصه التي تؤدي الى ما يعرف
في المنطقه الحمراء حيث المقر ال- ال-
الحكوميه وال- الحي الدبلوماسي اا في
اقليم البنجاب همم حكومه الانصاف بصعامه
عمران خان هي هي من يسيطر على اقليم
الانجاب في في المجمل همم يعني لا توجد
اجراءات فوق العاده في اقليم البنجر لان
هي حكومه حزب الانصراف وهناك ربما
التسهيلات همم للمحتاجين لان نزول الشارع
في اقليم لكن هنا في سنابات السلطات همم
هي الان في حاله من اليقظه والترقب تحسبا
من همم يعني همم ربما قدوم بعض المتظاهرين
من المدن المجاوره لكن حتى اللحظه كل
الانظار في التجه الى الرئيس السابق عمران
خان ليقرر ماذا سوف ااه ما هي الخطوه
المقبله له
[موسيقى]
في اسلام اباد او في الاقاليم الاخرى شكرا
لك من اسلام اباد مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن المسيني
في الخامسه سننتظر بعد الفاصل
الاف المحتاجين يتجمعون وسط العاصمه
الاسبانيه مدريد احتجاجا على التضخم
وارتفاع الاسعار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت الوكالات الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
الخارجي
النوويه في اوكرانيا وقالت الوكاله في
بيان ان المخطط تعمل الان عبر مولدات
الطوارئ وحضر مدير الوكاله رفيع الجروسي
من ان وضع محطه هون
لتفادي وقوع حادث النوويه
قال امين مجلس الامن الروسيني
روسيا منعت هجوم الاوكرانيا
للطاقه النوويه التي تسيطر عليها موسكو في
الجنوب الاوكراني واكد بتروشيف على ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تواصل قصف محطه الطاقه
النوويه باسلحه غربيه ما قد يؤدي الى
كارثه عالميه على حد وصفه
على العكس اعلنت شركه الطاقه النوويه
الاوكرانيه
للطاقه النوويه في جنوب البلاد انفصلت مره
اخرى عن شبكه الكهرباء بسبب القصف الروسي
مضيفه ان الوقود في المحطه التي يديرها
اوكرانيون يكفي لتشغيل المولدات لمده 15
يوما فقط وفي السياق افاد الجيش الاوكراني
ان القوه الروسيه تواصل الاجتماعي
ميدانيا استيقظ سكان اوكرانيا صباح اليوم
على قصف الروسيه استهدف مدن عده حيث اعلن
الجيش الاوكراني اسقاط عشر طائرات مسيره
ايرانيه الصنع بحسب مصادر العربيه قبل ذلك
اعلنت اوكرانيا ان روسيا شنت 80 هجوما
برجمات الصواريخ استهدفت اكثر من 20 مدينه
وبلده من بينها خرسان نيكولا
كما اتهمت كافه واحده من قوات روسيه في
محافظه لوغانس باستخدام المدنيين دروعا
بشريه من جهه اخرى تحسن القوات الروسيه
مواقعها في قريتي في الجنوب تمهيدا لهجوم
الاوكرانيا المرتقبه من جانبها افادت
وسائل الاعلام روسيه ان القوات المواليه
لروسيا فعلت انظمه الدفاع الجوي في مدينه
ملطفل بمقاطعه ذا فويس
ينضم الى الصحفيه محمد البابا محمد اهلا
بك معنا لنبدا من قطع الكهرباء عن محطه ذا
بوريجيا ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل
منذ منتصف الليل اعلنت الشركه المشغله
للمفاعل
النووي ان الكهرباء
بعد استهداف المحول الرئيسي في منطقه او
في مدينه
اطلقت من الجانب الذي يسيطر عليه روسيا في
مقاطعه ذكره مما ادى الى انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي بشكل كامل عن المدينه وبشكل
كامل ايضا عن المفاعل والان تعمل يعني
المفاعل يعمل بشكل استثنائي همم بالمولدات
والشركه تمتلك يعني همم يعني محروقات تكفي
لمده 15 يوما وهذه المره الرابعه
الذي يتعرض محطه تحويل الكهرباء القريبه
من همم
القريبه من المفاعل النووي والان اترك
الكهرباء عندنا يعني في العاصمه الاكرانيه
كيف يعني بعد التع هذه المنشاه المنشاه
للطاقه لقصف صاروخ انقطعت التيار
الكهربائي هذه الشركه ايضا حذرت ان
استمرار انقطاع التيار الكهربائي قد يعني
يشكل ازمه كبيره وخطيره جدا لان ما يعمل
الان داخل المفاعل هو فقط
المبردات الطاقه وفي حاله توقفت هذه
المبردات التي تعمل عبر المولدات سيكون
هناك يعني همم انفجار وتسريبات اشعاعيه
كالطالب مدن اوروبا وحتى روسيا اذا اردنا
ان نتحدث الان عن الجبهات خاصه
ماذا لدينا من جديد هناك
نعم بالفعل الجيش الاوكراني يعني قبل
حوالي ساعتين اعلن انه قصف قواعد عسكريه
للجيش الروسي بصواريخ هيمارس وبا المدفعيه
الثقيله التي تقع بالقرب من مدينه خرسان
في منطقه نوفيكا خوفتا في تلك المنطقه
ايضا تقوم القوات الروسيه باجلاء المدنيين
بعد ما انتهت من اجلاء المدنيين في مدينه
خرسون الان توسعت الى مقاطع
اجلاء المدنيين من القرى القريبه من مدينه
خرسون باتجاه مدينه
الروسيه تقوم باجلاء المدنيين قصر
الاوكرانيه يعني وارسالهم وتحويلهم الى
الاراضي الروسيه في منطقه ايضا تعرضت لقصف
صاروخي ومدفع عنيف جدا الجيش الروسي حاول
اقتح تلك المدينه للاسبوع الثالث على
التوالي ولكن اصطدم بالدفاعات الاوكرانيه
التي يعني استطاعت ضرب القوات الروسيه
التي تراجعت بعد ضربات ضربات بالمدفعيه
مدفعيه هاو هاوس وايضا في في بالقرب من
مدينه باخموس حاولت ايضا للقوات الروسيه
اقتحام المدينه مجددا للاسبوع الرابع او
الخامس على التوالي ولكنها تقصدين بمقاومه
الشرسه من الجيش الالكتروني شكرا لكم
محمد البابا على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل
ناقش قاده عسكريون روز كبار مؤخرا كيفيه
وسبل استخدام اسلحه تكتيكيه في ساحه
المعركه في اوكرانيا حسب ما ذكرت صحيفه
نوير تايمز باعت ذلك فيما تتصاعد المخاوف
الغربيه من استخدام موسكو للاسلحه النوويه
في اوكرانيا
تكتيكيه في حرب اوكرانيا يرسل رسائل
متعدده داخليا ودوليا
فان ورقه السلاح النووي التكتيكيه هي لعبه
خطيره يمارسها الجنرالات الروس لتحقيق
اقصى الصفات
داخليا يساهم هذا التهديد بحشد تاييد
الشعبي لما تطلق عليه روسيا الحمله
العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا وخاصه مع
تراجع هذا الدعم منذ بدات عمليات استدعاء
قوات الاحتياط وارسالها لساحات المعارك
ورغم عدمه وجود مؤشرات حقيقيه علانيه
روسيا لاستخدام هذا السلاح الا ان يرفع
نشرت ان قاده الروس بحثوا خلال اجتماعاتهم
هذا الخيار وهو ما اثار قلق المسؤولين
الامريكيين
التلويح بورقه السلاح النوويه يرسل ايضا
تهديدات للضغط على اوكرانيا للبدء في
مباحثات دبلوماسيه وتقديم تنازلات وخاصه
مع التغيرات على الارض من تقدم للقوات
الاوكرانيه وتراجع للقوات الروسيه
الرساله الثالثه التي تحملها التهديدات
الروسيه مواجهه لحلف الناتو الدول الغربيه
التي زودت اوكرانيا باطمان من الاسلحه
الحديثه مكانتها من تحقيق تقدم على الارض
التلويح بورقه السلاح النووي قد يكون
كافيا بحسب الصحيفه
لثاني واشنطن وحلفائها في الغرب عن ارسال
المزيد من هذه الاسلحه لاوكرانيا
يبحث وزراء خارجيه مجموعه الدول السبع
الكبرى اليوم في المانيا تقديم المزيد من
الدعم لاوكرانيا ياتي ذلك في عقاب الهجمه
الروسيه الاخيره على البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه التي تسببت في انقطاعات للكهرباء
على نطاق واساميه ان يتصدر الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا على الاجتماع الذي يستمر
اليومين بين وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
في مجموعه السبع في مدينه ماستر بغرب
المانيا كما سيكون من الموضوعات المطروحه
ايضا على جدول الاعمال الدور الصينيه
المتزايد حول العالم والاحتجاجات في ايران
وذكرت مفاوضه الاتحاد الاوروبي للطاقه
كادر
الاتحاد الاوروبي يستكشفوا مع الشركائي
سبل زياده الدعم لقطاع الطاقه الاكرانيه
من مدينه نصر الالمانيه تنضم الينا مراسله
العربيه راغب بهنام رغد اهلا بك معنا ماذا
لدينا من تفاصيل حول هذه الاجتماعات التي
بدات اليوم وستمر حتى غدا
اهلا بك ميسون يعني بالفعل قبل قليل انطلق
هذا الاجتماع رغم انه منذ الصباح كان هناك
اجتماعات ثنائيه بين وزراء خارجيه مجموعه
السبع انا لينابير بوك مضيفه هذه
الاجتماعيات
على الدعم الاضافي الذي يمكن تقديمه
لاوكرانيا خاصه مع حلول فصل الشتاء والان
يعني سيركزون على تقديم هذا الدعم في قطاع
الكهرباء وقطاع التدفئه هي قالت بانه
روسيا دمرت قرابه 30 الى 40% من القدره
اوكرانيا على انتاج الطاقه الكهربائيه
وبانه دول المجموعه ستبحث الان همم تعويض
اوكرانيا هذه الطاقه وقالت ايضا بانها
سترسل لها ادوات للتدفئه لكي تمكنها من
اجتياز فصل
يبدو بانه قطع الاتصال مع زميله رغده
بهنان نحاول ان نعود اليها حاله ما يتم
اصلاح هذا العطله التقنيه يبدو بان راغده
عادت الينا تفضل لراغده
نعم كنت اقول بانه ايضا هناك ملف مهم جدا
سيكون على طاوله يعني وزراء الخارجيه هذه
المره هو ملف العلاقه مع الصين هذا يعني
الملف يتزامن ايضا مع زياره يقوم بها
المستشار الالماني
اعتذر من رداءات الصوت وانقطاع الصوره
ايضا بهنا مراسلت العربيه كنتي معي من
المانيا نحاول ان نعود اليك اذا تم اصلاح
هذا العطله التقنيه
نفره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه استخدام ممرات
الحبوب في البحر الاسود لاغراض عسكريه ان
في الاوكرانيه جاء بعد وقت قصير من اتهام
وزير الخارجيه الروسي كيدز بانها تستخدم
مرات الحبوب في البحر الاسود للاغراض
العسكريه وقال متحدث باسم الوزاره ان
اوكرانيا لم تعرض ابدا موانئ البحر الاسود
للخطر مؤكدا ان اوكرانيا لم تقدم حتى اي
تنازلات خارج اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب لاعاده
روسيا اليه مشددا على الالتزام بكافه بنود
الاتفاق
هذا وغدر تبع السفن المحمله بالاغذيه
الاوكرانيه اليوم موانئ البحر الاسود بعد
استئناف في روسيا لمشاركتها باتفاقي تصدير
الحبوب متابع
[موسيقى]
اعلن الكريم لان انا روسيا لن تقرر بعد ما
اذا كانت ستمدد ومشاركتها في اتفاق تسهيل
الصادرات الحبوب من موانئ البحر الاسود
الذي ينتهي في وقت لاحق من هذا الشهر
واوضح المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه
انها ستقرر تمديده مشيرا الى الحاجه
لتقييم شامل لفعاليه الاتفاق قبل اتخاذ
قرارا بشان التمديد ويفترات تمديد الاتفاق
الذي توسطت فيه تركيا والامم المتحده بين
روسيا واوكرانيا في التاسعه عشر من شهر
نوفمبر الحالي
من جانبه دعم ونسق السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيه البوريل الى ضروره
عدم استخدام الغذاء كسلاح الحرب مؤكدا على
حسابه في تويتر ان تصدير الحبوب امر اساسي
لمعالجه ازمه الغذاء العالميه التي تفاقمت
بسبب روسيا كما دعا جميع الاطراف لتجديد
اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود
سته من دول البلقان الطامحه للانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي على نبذ الصراعات مشيرا
الى ان الحرب في اوكرانيا تجبر في اوروبا
على الوحده
عشان الحرب الروسيه الوحشيه ضد اوكرانيا
على الوقوف معا للحفاظ على حريه اوروبا
وامينها لقد حان الوقت للتغلب على
الصراعات الاقليميه التي استمرت لفتره
طويله جدا والصراعات التي تفرق بينكم
وتعقد ولكم عن مسارها الاوروبي يجب تسريع
عمليه التطبيع بين صربيا
لذا دعونا نقوم بذلك
الاردني ايمن الصفدي على وحده الاراضي
السوريه وحق السوريين في تقرير مصيرهم
اكدنا وحده الاراضي السوريه كامله وادعمها
حق السوريين في تقرير مصيرهم كما بحثنا
ايضا المسارات الاخرى المتعلقه بالقرارات
الاميه ونحن نرحب بمسائل الاردن في تشجيع
التسويه السياسيه السوريه في اطار
الجامعات العربيه كما اكدنا على اهميه
تفعيل ادخال المساعدات لدمشق طبقا لقرار
الامم المتوصل اليه في يوليو
الاردني
السوريه خصوصا الوضع في الجنوب السوري
فضلا عن قضيه تهريب المخدرات وانعكاسات
ذلك على ان سوريا
تواجد الروسي في سوريا بعامل الاستقرار في
ظل غياب الحل السياسي للازمه السوريه
تركيزنا كان على الازمه السوريه خصوصا
الوضع في الجنوب السوري والاخطار الكامنه
في حال
اللاستقرار التي تعمق معاناه اشقائنا
وتهدد امننا الوطني بحثنا الخطوات
المطلوبه لتحديد هذا التهديد وتوفير الحد
اللازم من الاستقرار في الجنوب السوري
هناك خطر تهريب المخدرات الى الاردن وعبره
والميليشيات التي تدعم عمليات التهري بهذه
وغيرها من الاعمال العدوانيه والازدياد في
البور الارهابيه واخطار اخرى والتواجد
الروسي في الجنوب السوري هو عامل استقرار
همم في هذه الظروف التي يبقى فيها الحل
السياسي للازمه هدفا لم يتحقق
تجمع عائلات المحتاجين وسط العاصمه
الاسبانيه مدريد بدعوه من اتحاد العمال
وذلك احتجاجا على ارتفاع التضخم وزياده
الاسعار وضعف الرواتب
[موسيقى]
في الخامس المتابع بعد الفاصل
اليونسكو تحذر من ان ثلث الانهار الجليديه
في مواقع التراث العالمي ستختفي بحلول 20
اهلا بكم من جديد وجه 40 محاميا ايرانيا
بارزا في مجال حقوق الانسان الانتقاد علنا
لحكام البلاد وعبروا عن اعتقادهم بان
النظام سيسقط نظرا لان اجراءات القمع
العنيفه لم تعد تخيفوا المحتاجين في انحاء
البلاد وقال المحامي في بيان لرويترز ان
الحكومه لا تزال غارقه في الاوهام وتعتقد
ان بامكانها الاصوات عبر القمع والاعتقال
والقتل قبل ذلك اطلقت قوه الامن الايرانيه
النار على المشاركين في مراسم اقيمت في
مدينه كرج لاحياء ذكرى مقتل ضحايا
الاحتجاجات الاخيره في ايران وفقا لقناه
ايران انترناشيونال وذكرت القناه انا
اعدادا ضخمه من المشاركين في المراسل
اغلاق الشوارع على القريبه من مكان التجمع
في مدينه كرج الواقعه على بعد 20 كيلو متر
غربي طهران حيث ردده دفاتر مناهضه للنظام
الايراني
اعلن انا بل اش على محتجون في مدينه كرج
الايرانيه النار في سياره تابعه للشرطه
احتجاجا على سياسه القمع التي تنتهيجها
قوات الامن ضد المحتاجين نتبع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قبل ذلك افادت منظمه حقوقيه ايرانيه ان
قوات الامن قتلت حوالي 300 متظاهر منذ 17
من سبتمبر الماضي حتى امس وقالت وكاله
وهران المانيه بحقوق الانسان انه من بين
القتلى 47 طفلا وقدرت المنظمه وانا اكثر
من 14 الف سنه تقيل خلال الاحتجاجات مؤكده
انه هي الكثيرين منهم لا تسالوا غير
معروفه
[موسيقى]
اما في مدينه قزوين غرب طهران
يوما على مقتل الشاب جواد حيدري وهو احد
ضحايا الاحتياجات المستمر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من لندن ينضم الي البحر في الشان الايراني
يعرف نصر بس اذا عارف اهلا بكم معنا هلا
عدم الخوف من هذا القمع من هذا العنف
المستخدم تجاه المحتاجين هو الذي يعطي
حقيقه زخما لهذه الاحتجاجات التي لا تشبه
الاحتجاجات السابقه في السنوات الماضيه
تحيه طيبه لك استاذه ميسون والمشاهدين
العربيه الكرام الواقع دعينا قبل ان يجيب
على هذا السؤال ان يشير الى نقطه مهمه
المرشد الايراني بالامس عندما
يعني قال خطبته عن استخدم صيغه الماضي الى
الاحداث ولا الاحتجاجات الماضيه وكانها
صفحه انطوت لكنما اعتقد بان هنالك رمزيه
كبيره
بعد يوم من هذا الخطاب تخرج هذه الالاف
المؤلفه بمدن شمالي وشر وغرب البلاد بهذه
الاعداد لذلك نحتفظ بان هنالك عزيمه
واصرار موجود في كل البلاد يجعل من هذه
الاحتجاجات حراكا ثوريا واقعيا لا يستطيع
النظام الايراني من خلال ماكنته الاعلاميه
او صرف الحديث عن انه
طواف صفحته صفحتها همم
ربما التعامل معها فيما يبدو بان النقطه
الثانيه والمهمه ااا ان النظام الايراني
لا يريد ان يستجيب الى مطالب المحتجين
وهذا بالتالي يجعلها تستمر حتى اا يعني
هذا هو السؤال لماذا لا يجيب مثلا او
يستجيب الى القليل من المطالب حتى يمتص
غضب الشارع لماذا دائما يرفض هذا الامر
ويعتبر بان كل هذه الاحتياجات هي ليست فقط
غير مؤامره خارجيه من الدول العدو لايران
قد تكون احد النقاط المهمه هنالك تعبير
استخدامه المتظاهرين كثيرا وحتى المحللين
همم
اعذرني على المقاطع ولكن الان ايضا خبر
عاجل عن وزير الامن الايراني الذي يهدد
مشددا المحتاجين ويقول بان اعمالكم لن تمر
من دون رده اذن دائما التهديدات ما زالت
مستمره من قبل المسؤولين الايراني على
اللسان وزير الامن الايراني اتفضل
بالفعل يعني انا اعتقد بان هنالك تعبير
استخدامه كثيرا المعارضه الايرانيه وربما
سمعناه وحتى من قبل المحتاجين ان
الاستجابه الى مطالب المحتاجين فيما يبدوا
تشبه سقوط جدار برلين عندما عندما يسقط
هذه الجدال سيسقط النظام برمته همم وخاصه
المساله الحجاب ونحن نعرف ان هنالك عقليه
اصوليه تحكم البلاد وهنالك حتى ربما
الجانب الجمهوريه الذي كان يمثله
الاصلاحين همم ربما همم تم التخلي عنه
بشكل كامل وبالتالي احتفظ بان اي استجابه
الى مطالب المحتاجين تعني سقوط النظام
بالنسبه ايضا لاستمرار هذه الاحتجاجات هل
العزيمه فقط عدم الخوف هو الذي من الممكن
ان يصلها الى نتيجه ام هي بحاجه الى هذا
الدعم الخارجي الذي لم تنله حتى الان
يعني فيما يبدو ان نحتفظ بان هذا الدعم
الخارجي سيلعب الدوري
المهم لكن انما يعني بكل الاحداث التي
حدثت في ايران ربما عامل الداخلي هو
الحاسب يعني في خلال 150 سنه الماضيه
الاحداث التي حدثت غالبا ما كانت ربما
العامل الداخلي هو العامل الحاسم واخرها
ربما همم ثوره عام 1979 التي قامت قام بها
الشعوب وليس الملائكه همم يروج هذا الامر
يؤدي او ربما يجعلنا ان نصل الى هذه
النتيجه بان العامل الداخلي هو الحاسم
لكما العوامل الخارجيه ستلعب الدوري
المساند وفيما يبدو بان مع الاحداث التي
حدثت همم في اوروبا يبدو بانه هنالك مسار
همم بالتدرج همم يستجيب او يسمع او يحاول
ان يسمع ما يجري في شوارع
ايرانيه عارف نصر على المشاركه معنا في
الخامسه
قالت كوريا الشماليه ان الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه قامت بمخاطره كبرى واتخذت
القرار الخاطئ بتمديد التدريبات القوات
الجويه وابقى وكاله الانباء الكوريه
الشماليه تاتي تصريحات بيوم بيانج في
الوقت الذي تجري فيه الولايات المتحده بل
تجري الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
اكبر تدريبات جهويه مشتركه بينهما على
الاطلاق
وسع وابل من الصواريخ التي اطلقتها كوريا
الشماليه على مدار ال 24 ساعه الاخيره
اعلنت كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان انابيونغ
يونغ اطلقت صاروخ باليستيا عابرا للقارات
لكنهما رجح ان تكون هذه العمليه قد بائت
بالفشل وعلى الرغم من تحذير حكوميه سابق
بان احد الصواريخ حلق فوق اليابان فان
طوكي قالت ان هذا غير صحيح وقال وزير
الدفاع الياباني انا الحكومه فقدت اثر
الصاروخ الاول فوق بحر اليابان ما دفعها
الى تصحيحه تصحيحتها من جهه اخرى اكد
مسؤول ياباني سابق من سقوط الراس الحربي
في البحر بين شبه الجزيره الكوريه
واليابان الا انه شدد على ان الحطام الذي
كان يتحرك بسرعه عاليه ربما يكون قد مر
فوق اليابان
حتى الان لم نتاكد من اي تقارير عن وقوع
اضرار فيما يتعلق باطلاق كوريا الشماليه
للصواريخ البالستيه الاخيره قدمنا على
الفور شكوى قويه واحتجاجا ضد كوريا
الشماليه من خلال سفاره في بكين سنتعاون
بشكل وثيق مع المجتمع الدولي بما في ذلك
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه للرد
والحمايه ارواح وثروات الناس في اليابان
سنواصل جمعه المعلومات وتحليلها ووطعها كل
جهودنا للبقاء في حاله تاهب القصوى
الشماليه
بين سكان اليابان المجاوره حتى بعد تاكيد
السلطات المحليه عدم تحليق اي صاروخ
بالسياسه عبر القارات فوق اراضيها
طيب كويس
الامريكي
تكتمل حلقاتها في كولورادو غير ان هذا
الخلاف مع المرشح لعضويه مجلس الشيوخ
الجوع ضايق قد يطيح الاخير بصحب المقعد من
منافسه الديمقراطي مايكل
[موسيقى]
احدى ساحات المعارك ترامب في كواليس الحزب
الجمهوريه تشمل كولورادو فهناك دخل بحرب
كلاميه اخرى مع المرشح عن الحزب العضويه
مجلس الشيوخ جودي الاخيره ارتكب غلطه قد
يمررها سياسيون اخرون لكنه وخزت ترامب حين
اكد عدم دعمه بالانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله ان قرر الرئيس السابق الترشح لا
بل اعلن ادعي على نيته تسير حمله الناشطه
لدعم اي منافس لترامب من الجمهوريين عام
2024 امثله بسكوت من سوس كارولينا
والسفينه في عهد ترامب نيكها اليه ومن ضمن
عثرات السنه الجمهوري ايضا وصف مبارزه
ثانيه بين بيضا وترامب على الرئاسه
بالممزقه للبلاد كما شدد على وجوب فعل
ترامب المزيد لمنع هجوم السادس من يناير
على مبنى الكونجرس
توني 4
فعلى موقعه الخاص تروس سخره ترامب منه
واصفا اياه بالرايينو اي الجمهوريه على
الورق فقط وهي عباره مهمه يستخدمها
المحافظون لوصف اعضاء الحزب الاكثر
اعتدالنا مضيفا ان ماجا لا تصوت للاغبياء
ذوي الاحواه الكبيره وفقه تعبيره وذلك في
اشاره للحركه التي تحمل اسم فلنجعل امريكا
عظيمه مره اخرى عنواننا حملته الانتخابيه
عام 2016
[موسيقى]
حلقات الاخضر
سياسيه مؤكدا اعطاء الحقل ترامب لابداء
رايه ونيل حق نفسه
الحالي
ودعم المستقلين والمعتدلين في جميع انحاء
كلورادو لتسجيل النقاط على حساب البنات
ينهي اماله بتحقيق المعادله الرابحه
[موسيقى]
تستعد مدينه شرم الشيخ لاستضافه القمه
السابعه والعشرين مؤتمر المناخ والمقرره
في السادس من نوفمبر الجاري في مشاهدت مصر
انطلاقه عدد من المبادرات لتوعيه
المواطنين حول اضرار استخدام المواد
البلاستيكيه وتاثيرها على البيئه
على احد شواطئ الاسكندريه يجمع هؤلاء
الشباب مع تصل اليه ايديهم من المخلفات
البلاستيكيه من على الرمال قبل ان تسحبها
الامواج الى اعماق البحر انهم متطوعون
استجابوا لدعوات للمشاركه في حمله لتنظيف
الشواطئ من الملوثات
قد ايه ان هو كم مليون يدخل
اي مسطحات من ايات تقريبا كل سنه اا
فتبتدي نحاول شويه شويه ان احنا نغير
التفكير نغير اا الطريقه اللي احنا
بنتعامل بها مع المخالفات بشكل عام انا
حامله تو هي احدى الفعاليات التي تنظمها
شركات مهتمه بنشر ثقافه الحفاظ على البيئه
والتي تسعى لتقليل الاخطار التي تمثلها
النفايات البلاستيكيه على مياه البحر
وشواطئها عشان كده ابتدينا الحمله دي
ونفهم الناس ان ان البلاستيك او ده هو
مسبب الان لما في صناعته وبيلوث البيئه
وبيقتل كانت الكائنات البحريه لما يكون
بيترني فهو عامل سيء جدا من جميع نواحي من
بدايه نشئته لحد نهايته في البحر
احدى المناطق الصناعيه في ضواحي العاصمه
يجري يلعب عمله على قدم وساق لاعاده تدوير
البلاستيك المشروع ولي المره الاولى في
البلاد يحول لمخلفات البلاستيك الى منتج
النهائي من البلاط احنا شغالين في حلقه
مفرغه عمالين نعيد ونزيد نعيد ونزيد في
مجال البلاستيك وبنعملش حاجه مفيده فربنا
سبحانه وتعالى هدانا الفكره ان احنا نخترق
الدايره دي ونعمل منتج صديق للبيئه
وغير ضار بالعمال اللي شغاله فيه همم
همم مطلوب جدا جدا جدا للتصدير في اوروبا
عشان الجو هناك المطر والسقعه فمحتاجين
المنتج ده كويس جدا واحنا اعدمنا
البلاستيك بالمنتج بتاعنا اللي هو عاملينه
صديق للبيئه هذه النماذج من الحملات
والمشروعات تاتي قبل انعقاد مؤتمر المناخ
كوب 27 في مدينه شرم الشيخ ليبقى التساؤل
والتحدي في قدره تغيير السواد الاعظم من
المصريين من انماط تفكير سابقا واستعابه
لتغيرات وتحديات تتعلق بصحتهم ومستقبل
ابنائهم واحفادهم احمد عثمان العربيه
الاسكندريه
ذكر تقرير لمنظمات اليونيسكو ان بعض
الانهار الجليديه الاكثر شهره في العالم
بما في ذلك الموجوده في جبال دولاميت في
ايطاليا ومتنزهه ويلستون في امريكا ستختفي
بحلول 20 50 بسبب الاحتباس الحراري
[موسيقى]
نشره الخامسه انتهت اشكركم طيب المتابعه
في امان الله
[موسيقى]